you're regularly scheduled update
on
white women pretending to be ethnic this
from the New York Post
a progressive activist
Raquel Evita Saraswati
she is a Muslim Progressive activist
she is an Arab woman she is a Latina she
has made this ethnic
identity part of her activism for 20
years and it turns out you're going to
be shocked to hear this she's just a
regular white lady
39 years old
was just outed by The Intercept for
pretending to be
South Asian Latina
and Arab
uh she she spoke to boston.com in 2004
about her upcoming wedding saying she
she wanted to do something to respect
her Arab and Latin culture actually her
name is Rachel Elizabeth Seidel
she uh she's referred to in that article
as Raquel Evita Seidel I guess she has
dropped the Seidel now she's Sarah
sawati and her mother Carol Peroni
says that it's all Bs and her family is
white as the driven snow
I call her Rachel I don't know why she's
doing what she's doing I'm as white as
the driven snow and so is she I'm German
and British her father was Calabrese
Italian which to be fair is a racially
liminal group of people I happen to be
Calabrese as well she's chosen to live a
lie and I find that very very sad what
is Sarah swati's job
do you think she's a truck driver no do
you think she's an electrician no she is
of course
the chief Equity inclusion and culture
officer
of a philadelphia-based group The
American friends service committee which
is a leftist Quaker group that fights
violence inequality and oppression
she's the latest Rachel dollazole but
there have been many Rachel Dollaz holes
since then lots of white women usually
women
pretend to be
other ethnic groups why is that
because
exhibit Z exhibit number 10 576.
that white privilege
does not exist
it does not exist certainly as our
culture pretends that it exists you
don't get special social points for
being white in fact white people are the
only group in our culture that one can
legally discriminate against and a
socially insult exclude ostracize where
it's actually encouraged by our culture
to attack white people and so
white people are pretending to be other
races
it's just basic incentives the proof of
the pudding is in the tasting
you don't see many if any black people
pretending to be white people you don't
see many Arab people or middle eastern
people pretending to be white people in
fact
in the U.S census Arab and Middle
Eastern people used to be classified as
white then there was a movement over the
last 10 years to reclassify that group
as Middle Eastern and North African Mena
Linda sarsour the leftist activist was
one of the people pushing this why was
she pushing this if there were a
privilege associated with being white
don't you think that the people who were
already lumped in as being white would
want to remain White
they're not doing that though why
because being white is the only group
with which there is not a social
privilege Associated so they're trying
to be some other group and yet if you
went out and you pulled a hundred people
on the street
in New York San Francisco Chicago
Washington DC if you pulled any CNN
Watchers so I guess you'd have to go to
the airport for that and you said hey
which group is the most socially
privileged
you would hear a lot of people say oh
it's white people
it's white people it's the opposite of
reality so often we we can just be
hypnotized
by by the popular culture but this is
the proof that it's all Bs speaking of
privilege
speaking of white white privilege
a gang member in La is a Korean guy
this Korean guy comes with his family to
America as a kid
he then joined a gang and committed
murder
and then he went to a prison for that
and now he's being deported because he
got out of prison which is absurd the
guy committed murder he should at the
very least be in prison for the rest of
his life
but okay fine let's say
[Music]
for let's let's say we're a legitimate
reason for which he was granted some
clemency here some mercy he was allowed
out of prison he is being deported he's
not an American citizen he is a Gangster
and a murderer and so he's being
deported this is being reported in the
New York Times or I'm sorry the LA Times
as a kind of a sad story
this guy Justin Chung
Justin Tung Chung was brutally honest
admitting that it took him years to feel
remorse he wanted to share his
complicated journey and he was rallying
support for another fight
because of the murder he committed when
he was 16 he had lost his chance to
apply for a green card he's on the verge
of being deported to South Korea the
country he left is a two-year-old
especially being Korean I do want to be
private for my family said Chung 33 but
I have to fight
I have to do something before I get
deported
no you don't just go go away go away
you're very very lucky that you were
allowed out of prison
because of the Democrat policies of
people like Gavin Newsom you're very
very lucky that you were not executed
when you committed that Murder In Cold
Blood when he committed that murder
he was in a gang he thought he was
killing people of a rival gang he just
didn't like the cut of their jib or the
kind of clothes they were wearing so he
went to murder them and it turned out
the people that he murdered were not in
any gang at all
they were just in the wrong place at the
wrong time in this cold-blooded psycho
murdered them
so now he's getting deported and now
that's the sob story
that's the sob story that is how
much our culture favors
immigrants
that the foreigners the people who they
look different they sound a little
different that's how insanely our
culture favors them is that they can
come here literally commit murder
and they're still the sympathetic
characters in the story
You Remember When Donald Trump in 2016
he said my followers love me so much I
could shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue and
I wouldn't lose a single vote and the
left used this line they said oh my
goodness this is cultish behavior this
is horrible can you imagine what a
terrible country we're living in where
that sort of statement can be true well
it's not exactly true of trump his
followers are pretty loyal but he was
exaggerating for Comic effect
that is true when it comes to the libs
and immigration they could literally
murder people they do regularly murder
people
and the libs will not lift a finger to
do anything about it in fact they will
lift a finger to try to stop these poor
put upon murderers from being deported
uh rest of the show starts now you don't
want to miss it go to dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign